bonsoir retour sur vous propose cette
semaine de revenir sur l'engagement des
milices jana éleveuse soucieuse de la
cause animale qui ne supportaient plus
il emmener ses vaches à l'abattoir
c'était il ya un peu plus d'un an
souvenez-vous dans son métier d'éleveur
de vaches charolaises emilie et aime
presque tous y compris le contact avec
la clientèle puisque depuis dix ans elle
pratique la vente directe
il y à une seule chose qui cloche c'est
la question de l'abattage
même si avec la batteur d'autun et que
j'ai confiance dans tous les
intervenants là bas ne serait ce que de
faire une heure de route d'emmener ma
vache d'ici à autun ça me prend une
heure de route de l'enlever de son
environnement naturel et l'emmener dans
ce lieu qu'elle connaît pas c'est
toujours une strauss de stress en suède
ou ml s'est rendu récemment les éleveurs
ont désormais un autre choix
c'est cette unité mobile d'abattage qui
répond bien sûr à toutes les normes
réglementaires
cette visite a été pour elle une
véritable révélation
cela fait trois ans emilie est rentré de
suède avec la conviction que son métier
qu'elle aime doit changer pour les
éleveurs comme pour ses bêtes auquel
elle est très attachée
voilà c'est drôle c'est une vache qui
est née
on s'est installé en 2007 et c'était
l'année des c'est donc on l'appelait
canaille à côté elle a même âge et dont
elle s'appelle kabech au fond il ya
brune fin bref on a en a dans toutes un
nom on trouve que c'est important
qu'elle a un nom
on les amis ou à l'abattoir c'est
vraiment je fais parce qu'on a besoin de
vendre la viande pour gagner notre vie
et que c'est indispensable mais c'est
clair que c'est pas du tout un truc que
j'adore et puis il ya des périodes où
j'ai ce passe des moments où je les
emmène à l'abattoir parce que c'est
physiquement trop dur pour moi une boule
au ventre
quoi des congrès charge dans la vanne
parce qu'on sait que c'est leur dernier
voyage qu'on les emmène il ya un peu un
sentiment effectivement peut-être de les
trahir
un mal-être pour l'éleveur mais aussi
pour l'animal qui subit le transport
parfois longs jusqu'à l'abattoir une
spécialité bien de chez nous la volonté
vraiment en france a été de concentrer
tous les outils d'abattage dans pour les
faire de plus en plus gros pour que
économiquement on soit plus compétitif
et ça a été vraiment de massifier les
outils dans certaines zones et donc de
fait il ya des zones qui se retrouve
complètement dépourvues d'outils
alors ici en bourgogne on a encore des
outils d'abattage mais il ya des
départements où il n'ya plus d'outils
adaptés agents amenés l'abattoir à
l'éleveur une solution qui vient
d'ailleurs mais qu'émilie voit comme un
outil de proximité éthique pour mieux
exercer alors lavage à grande eau par ou
et qu'est ce qui fait qu'elle n'a pas de
stress comme elle pourrait avoir si vous
aviez à les déplacer
en fait elles rentrent donc camions par
ici en traversant fait la notation de
complètement traversé l il ya une porte
de l'autre côté qui est ouverte et ans
généralement faut réfléchir cette
pression mais le fait qu'elle voie le
jour de l'autre côté elle traverse ce
qu'elles m'ont assez naturellement en
pensant qu'elle valait de l'autre côté
et en sortir et une fois dedans kényan
en fait il
derrière et l'opérateur arrive très
rapidement avec sa main positionner le
matador exactement où il faut pour
mettre à mort un animal une vache
détendue une exécution éthiques
le gage d'une viande de meilleure
qualité emilie en a fait un combat et
elle vient de remporter une bataille
l'autorisation d'expérimenter ce projet
pour quatre ans malgré l'opposition des
industriels du secteur
ça fait 40 ans qui raconte à tout le
monde que pour être économiquement
rentable il n'y a pas le choix faut
faire des grosses battoir faut faire du
volume et c'est que par le volume qu on
arrive à s'en sortir économiquement
voilà typiquement on a un abattoir dans
lequel on fera dix fois moins d'animaux
par jour que dans ces unités
industrielles et qui coûte relativement
cher quand même donc si on arrive en
plus à montrer dans notre modèle
économique qu'on y arrive ça vient les
faire mentir ce qu'ils racontent depuis
40 ans pourrait minilab atlan mobile
c'est une pratique plus transparente de
son métier plus confortable aussi pour
les éleveurs ils sont une centaine à la
suivre dans cette voie aujourd'hui et à
partager ses valeurs
un éleveur y travaillent tout les jours
de la semaine
il prend souvent pas de vacances et
voilà et de voir que tout cet
investissement au final n'en retire même
pas de salaire ils doivent vivre à
partir de des fois de rien ou des fois
du salaire de sa conjointe
c'est assez dévalorisant donc voilà
c'est ça va être c'est cause d'acquis
vont animer je pense de défendre
vraiment le revenu aux paysans
et puis qu'ils puissent avoir le droit a
priori comme n'importe qui dans cette
société à être heureux quoi cet autre
combat elle compte le mener après
l'aboutissement de ce projet l'abattoir
mobile est en cours de construction
les premiers essais devraient commencer
début 2005
[Musique]